Speaker 1: All right.
Let's get to audience emails.
The mail bag for the week.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com.
There are some very aggressive ones this week
and I will let you know, sometimes a tweet
will be used, sometimes a YouTube comment
might be included or a Facebook comment or
whatever the case may be.
We start today with Donny via Facebook, who
and I'm going to try to do my best reading
of this that I can.
Donny had an opinion and wrote in shortly
after the midterm election and said suffer
from tds much you pedo supporting lib tard
goof go sniff a little kid like your potato
in chief pedo joe then go smoke crack with
hunter and f some hookers.
You and you is misspelled almost every time
effing lib tard loser goof.
They then got our standard auto response that
I'm not going to be writing them back and
then they wrote back get effed.
So someone very much struggling with emotions
and that type of thing.
I do often wonder like, what type of job could
this person have?
Could this be your accountant, for example,
where you go in and they go, listen.
I would advise you to take the full 179 depreciation
on your new £6,000 vehicle.
Excuse me a second.
You pedal sniffing?
Sorry.
I'm just writing a message.
Go get.
Are these people, are doctors, are accountants,
etc. or not?
Just a question.
I don't know.
I never know the answer.
Next message is another person on teaching
transgender.
This person wrote in and said, You lie when
you say they don't teach about trans.
It happened to my son and daughter at a young
age.
You P.O.S., who can't define woman.
I don't know if that's a question or a statement.
You looked like such a loser on Michael Knowles
show.
Laughable.
How smug of a liberal you looked like.
And what's wrong with singing our national
anthem?
Leave then.
That's a classic.
You don't like it?
Leave.
It's progressives like you who change everything
good in this country.
I know.
It's like we have weekends now and we have
minimum standards for health insurance and
minimum standards for education.
Give me a break, dude.
You're all sick.
And yes, I just paid 550 for gas, and our
store said they were late getting turkeys.
What guy talks about cooking a beautiful chicken?
See?
You change traditions.
I guilty as charged.
Okay.
For me spending, what is it, 6 hours with
a turkey in the oven and then you get it out.
And the dark meat is just.
It's just not that good.
Guys, let's not pretend like turkeys that
great.
Okay?
And then you've got the brass, then you're
slicing it and it's enormous and you're checking,
is it done or not?
I say get yourself a couple of just nicely
sized pasture, raised organic chickens, beautifully
crispy skin takes 45 to 75 minutes in the
oven.
Everybody's happy.
It's just better.
I'm not telling you to change your tradition.
I'm just telling you it's better.
And by the way, plenty of turkeys at every
grocery store I've been going to.
Okay.
Casey wrote in.
Casey says, David, seeing that many of Trump's
hand-picked candidates underperformed and
a clear split in the Republican Party is about
to materialize, do you think it's at all likely
Trump runs as an independent in 24 if the
Republican Party and media turn against him,
what do you think would happen if he just
took his base with him and started his own
party?
I doubt he'll do it or that it would occur
to him, but it's something I could see him
doing, if nothing else, out of pure narcissism.
I think that that's actually the critical
part of this question.
If Trump actually cared about the Republican
Party, we would all be saying he would never
do that.
He would never run as an independent because
it would almost ensure, even if he just brought
over 10% of the Republican vote, 15%, some
small, relatively small amount, he guarantees
Democrats win.
But that's if Trump cared about the Democratic
the Republican Party.
Trump doesn't care about the Republican Party.
That's the reality.
And therefore, I do think it's possible that
Trump might run as an independent out of desperation,
out of humiliation, if indeed DeSantis just
outright defeats him in a primary.
I hope it happens.
I think it would be a great thing for the
country in that it would hurt both Trump and
whoever is the eventual Republican nominee.
I love it.
We should encourage Trump to do it.
Elon wrote in.
About MAGA as a mental illness.
This is interesting.
Ellen says, Hey, David, a few times on your
show you've wondered aloud about the cause
of the MAGA condition.
You expressed concern that you might be overstepping
by calling out their behavior if it's mental
illness that's causing it.
I think it's good you're considering that
it shows your empathy.
But I also suspect you believe, as I do, that
their court, their causes are multiple and
nuanced, and you're going to keep doing it
because the bottom line is we can't become
apathetic towards the movement.
I think the way you handle them is fine.
Very little mocking there, which is pretty
impressive.
Yeah.
When we say.
Is MAGA a mental illness in some of those
people?
I'm not laughing at it.
I think we need to deal with mental illness
in this country.
If we determined.
I mean, listen.
I want undiagnosed and untreated mental illness
to be diagnosed and to be treated.
That whatever it is.
And if that mental illness is part of why
someone falls for MAGA delusion, it's good
to treat it both because it's better to help
people when they're struggling with mental
illness, and it might prevent us from going
down this insane path of Trumpism once again.
So I appreciate Alan's comment very much.
Eric wrote in, Are people like Mike Lindell
and Herschel Walker part of the MAGA grift
or victims of it?
This is another interesting perspective from
Eric.
Eric says, Hey, David, do you think people
like Mike Lindell and Herschel Walker are
knowingly part of the MAGA grift?
Or were they victims of it?
What I mean is do these mid-level frontmen
know it's all a grift?
Or are they just patsies being exploited due
to their celebrity status and psychological
vulnerability, for example?
I don't think Herschel Walker woke up one
morning and decided running for the U.S. Senate
is the next logical step in his professional
and personal life.
Obviously, somebody approached him with the
idea.
Likewise, Mike Pillow is destroying himself
financially and seems to be used by other
people as a pawn and ATM machine for, I guess,
their own profit and ambition.
The reason I ask this is while we can't change
the minds of MAGA followers directly, it would
be great if we could find a way to wake up
these linchpin people to reality.
Yeah, I. I don't know the answer to that.
Mike Pillow seems like a true believer.
Herschel Walker kind of seems like he might
have been drifted in with appeals to his narcissism
and ego.
And that's what you have to understand.
Ego is a common thing.
Okay.
If you have a show like mine on some fundamental
level.
You think your opinions are interesting enough
for other people to listen to them rather
than to just make their own show?
Right.
So they cannot be denied that on some level,
I must think.
Well, I don't know.
What I have to say is at least interesting
enough that I should make a show with elected
officials.
This is significantly bigger and we've looked
at traits of narcissism, etc.
And what happens with a lot of these people
is they become convinced, like Trump did and
apparently like Herschel Walker, that they're
somehow needed by the country, that they're
doing some great thing.
And I wonder whether at this point it's too
late for Herschel Walker to be talked out
of that he may soon be gone if we do our job
in in the state of Georgia.
And we'll get back to that in a moment.
Interesting email from Julian.
Julian says Interesting subreddit drama.
David, an interesting segment for The Bone
is Show where something could be reading replies
on the conservative subreddit.
Very interesting to see what some of them
are saying about Trump.
Imagine he runs as an independent in 24 and
splits the vote.
I recommend checking this out as it reminds
me of the betting market segments in terms
of indication of conservative opinion.
Yeah, if you check out the conservative subreddit
like Reddit dot com slash r slash conservative,
you will find that there is a not insignificant
portion that is mad at Trump and ready to
abandon Donald Trump.
Now what if anything, it tells us about 24.
I think it's just way too early.
But it's interesting.
Let's deal with the December run off first.
Carrie wrote in and said, Please come to Georgia.
We need you.
I am figuring out Carrie, how can I get as
involved as possible in Georgia, given that
I don't think I can make it down there in
the next few weeks.
And we're going to be doing a bunch of stuff
critically important to get 51 rather than
50.
Imagine a supposed red wave.
In which Democrats gain a seat in the Senate.
I mean, that's just that's amazing.
Brian wrote in, Brian has sad news and says,
You lost a daily listener.
I'm sure you don't care.
But I actually loved your show prior to the
last few days with all your negativity which
never happened.
Sorry.
Need more positive in my life.
I know you want to keep it real, but holy
cow, your negativity was the worst.
I'm switching to Mighty Midas as I watched
them as well, and they were dead on ride with
all their content and even head on.
A guest that nailed the election that Fox
News had made fun of their guest was 100%
right.
Listen.
I was.
As honest as possible in the lead up to the
midterm.
I said the momentum had shifted to Republicans
and that is indeed the case.
What over the summer was looking like a much
bigger Democratic victory in the Senate came
down to just one or two seats.
A lot of these races ended up way closer.
Look at Fetterman odds, way closer than it
was supposed to be in July.
I correctly told you the momentum is going
to the Republicans and I said the specific
numbers may be skewed because of right wing
pols that are being included in the averages.
I was very upfront.
And the most important thing I said was, we're
so close that the polling no longer matters.
It's about voting.
Oh, Fetterman is up three or down two.
It doesn't matter if we are allowed to vote
in Pennsylvania.
We vote in Pennsylvania.
So, yes, Brian is done with this show because
of that.
Because of something, I guess, that I don't
really understand.
I do appreciate all the very nice messages
I got from people saying, David, I think you
struck the right balance between this is the
polling.
Here are the limitations.
Here's what might be going on.
And making sure that everybody votes.
That was the critical message.
And enough people did, including 18 to 29
year olds, that the red wave ended up being
potentially a ripple.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
Sign up at join Packman dot com.
And of course we will be back Monday with
much, much, much more.